I believe in those rural days means you
can be anything you want to be and that
if you follow I've always believed that
everyone has a talent everyone I know
and I was not very good in school I was
I realized later that I had a focus
problem which a lot of people have which
they don't know at the time but I
remember thinking to myself but I had
this other side of me my younger
brothers the same way that if I really
go after that then I don't have to worry
about being good at all the other things
and it was something I realized my
brother went to comedy he couldn't
organize his checkbook I me and a lot of
people would get stumped by that and say
keep trying to make themselves better at
the things that they're not naturally
inclined to do and we said I'm not going
to be able to do this when I moved to
New York I won't be able to manage my
checkbook I'm not making enough money to
do it i'll live on pizza and beer but
i'm going to go for doing the best with
talent that i have which is solving
ideas and advertising and everything
else was a mess but as I built that the
other things took care of themselves and
if I try to spend all my mind that
didn't percentage of my mind and put it
into let me see if I can sit down and
figure out this math problem figure if I
can solve the way that you know I can
break down my budget and and do x and y
it just would be a waste and an
opportunity cost it would be too high I
had to just do what I did my younger
brother did that with comedy said look
I'm not going to be an accountant I'm
not going to be a you know a see rated
you know real estate guy I'm not going
to be a bad I mean we all could have
been needing over a lot of things but I
think we'd said but I'm really inclined
to do this if I can find a way to do
this I could be very good at this I
think a lot of people get I don't think
they get to do it they want to do
because they don't it can't figure out
what it follow it maybe they're not
encouraged my mother encouraged us to do
that to go with what we really felt we
felt passionate about and but we could
do naturally and that's easy your life
is you don't feel like it's work you're
just doing what you do naturally rather
than
trying to like you know go to law school
and you know which is fine but you know
it's just I couldn't spend the time in
the books but um